the phillies will raise the curtain on
really the biggest acquisition of the
offseason for the ball club and that is
zach wheeler one two swing
and a miss he got him got a piece of
that did aguilar but right into the
middle of romuto remuto
first strikeout for zach wheeler is it
philly
i have to watch that out towards
shortstop that was a nice hop to dd
gregorius and a double play wraps up the
inning
andy homer last night had two hits
overall
in the air to right field there's number
two and it's a long one
into the second deck dede gregorius has
just given the phillies a one-nothing
lead
what a beautiful swing wow incredible
how he easy swings with two strikes
bryce harper well he's been good in
situations with
ducks on the pond we do it again
bad time a breaking ball from caleb
smith he freezes bryce harper
it has been a struggle runner goes
wallach's throw to second
is in time as they get segura
so a caught stealing helps to get caleb
smith
out of this third inning at work the
balls are two strikes daguar he struck
out his first time up
swing at a miss three strikeouts
for wheeler this is about as much
trouble as wheeler's been in
all afternoon line
basin into center field that's going to
score brian anderson easily
love it with the ballpark empty you can
hear the energy on the marlins bench as
mickey rowe comes through
yet again ground ball
rojas jumps oh it's the jordans
it's got to be the over shoes youth you
know get him off the base a little more
and turn a double play
right over to third could be two segura
stays down on it gets one
over to first in time a double play a
five four
three double play the fourth of the day
for the phil's defense
all right so here is gosselin phil has
walked he is singled so far
in the air to left field going back on
it is dickerson back to the
boat
phil goslin has done it again
a two-run home run and the phillies take
a 3-1
lead see how hot this guy
is well he's staying that way dickerson
sends one down toward left field sliding
grab by mccutchen
what a play by andrew mccutchen one out
here in the seventh inning but he has
really been right around the strike zone
he only has the two walks
there he got him
98 up in the zone his final pitch of the
day
most likely that he picks up his fourth
strikeout of the afternoon
and bryce harper coming up
he bunts toward third that's going to be
a basic
it rolls just inside the third base bag
so bryce harper's first hit of the 2020
season is exactly what you expect
a bunt up the third base line now jt
deliver
we're in good shape out to center field
birdies going back toward the track to
the wall it is gone
off the brick wall in center field a
three-run
rocket off the bat of jt rio muto
and the phillies lead it six to one
two on and here's aguilar
hot shot to short knocked him right to
his fanny he flips to second
in time to get vr
that ball was smoked by aguilar phil
gosling two for two with a walk he
homered his last time
to right field that's pretty well hit
ramirez going back to the wall
it is god another home run for goslin
he's hit two today he is smoking hot
and the phillies lead it's 7-1 here is
deodos
guerra out in front
one away here in the ninth inning
sway gonna miss back-to-back strikeouts
from guerra fnatic
loving it trying to emulate a large
crowd with the
crowd noise in the background and the
one-two pitch
softly out toward the middle of the
diamond picked on a hot by
kingry and the ball game is over the
phillies bounced back with a heck of an
offensive
outburst today to win it 7-1 and give
joe girardi his first victory
as the phillies skipper